one of my least favorite qualities is
when I meet a lot of very successful
people and there's a bunch of them
whether they're famous or wealthy they
think that they got here on their own
and I always think no none of us got
here on their own I you know I never
want kids sure it's about hard work but
it's about all the other pieces that are
in place and some of those pieces are
pieces that the government has a big
piece a big part of in fact I'll tell
you just one part of that when I was 12
my daddy had a heart attack and my three
brothers are all off in the military at
that point it's just mom and dad and me
my mother's 50 years old never worked
outside the home we had long period with
no money coming in we lost the family
station wagon the bills pile up we're
about that far from losing our home and
I remember the day I walk into my
parents bedroom my mom's got her best
dress out and she pulls that dress on
she's crying she says I am NOT gonna
lose this house she puts on her high
heels she puts on her lipstick wipes her
eyes she walks to the Sears and gets a
minimum-wage job at Sears and here's the
key part that minimum wage job saved her
home it saved our family but it was a
time in America when a minimum-wage job
would keep a family of three afloat we
must raise the minimum wage
[Applause]
you're talking your book you really
can't a lot of attention with your
system is rigged speech and and you
really believe that the system is rigged
and that there are these incredible
benefits obviously to huge corporations
there's and and you contrast it with the
situation that a lot of young people are
out there with student loans yeah where
the student loans they're playing some
of them are paying twelve percent okay
yeah it's depending on when they got
them at 6% 8% 10% 12% if it got private
student loans it's even higher than that
and these are kids literally kids or
just young adults who were saddled with
a debt that they cannot possibly pay and
you contrast that with giant companies
that are paying next to nothing that's
right paying next to nothing in taxes so
here's the deal so I introduced a bill
to reduce the interest rate on student
loans yeah
okay I want you to understand about this
bill on reducing the interest rate on
student loans the interest rate on
student loans right now is set so that
after you account for the bad debt
losses the ones that go south and the
administrative costs in the cost of the
funds it's set to produce tens of
billions of dollars in profits for the
United States government just the ones
from 2007 to 2012 that little slice of
loans on target to produce 66 billion
dollars in profits for the United States
government the United States government
should not be making profits off the
backs of kids who are trying to get in
[Applause]
[Music]
but you have a plan on how you would pay
obviously the money's got to come from
somewhere if we refinance student debts
where would you be so here's the crazy
thing
you think the government in a democracy
could just say hey we're just going to
reduce the interest rate how about like
to a break-even point okay not even not
even subsidizing but just breakeven
problem is the government has already
pre spent all the profits on student
loans so if you want to reduce the
interest rate you've got to find
somebody else to put the money in to
fund the government over the next decade
or so and so what we proposed what I
said I thought we should do is we said
let's have millionaires and billionaires
pay taxes at at least the same rate that
middle-class families do and we'll use
that extra money
but that's where you get to the heart of
it because there is no clearer choice as
a government we can decide we're either
going to spend the same lump of money
either to keep tax loopholes open for
billionaires or to reduce the interest
rate on student loans and you want to
guess who's winning right now the
billionaires and that's wrong that's why
we have to fight back you know what
what's that way
you